hey guys Ryan writes here and I'm Murray
and tonight we're gonna watch the
trailer for a walk among the tombstones
I am really sensing every movie I'm an
American yeah it's a Liam Neeson movie
we're gonna watch it for a walk among
the tombstones yeah I don't know
anything about this movie sounds cool I
like being Neeson is like a 55 year old
action start we need people like that to
show that the elderly are still
functional and can work in this country
it's rated R for strong violence
disturbing images language and brief
nudity I hope you see it like the tip of
Liam Neeson's dick that would be awesome
but only briefly briefly like it well
you have to posit when you buy it on
blu-ray right I'll use Gardens
our self to deacon day of this boring
Washington Heights the cops didn't have
to pay for their drinks guys came into
place was it good
a lot of money
this is like a real movie there's gonna
be some action films
you've dealt with situations like this
killing yeah it did
dude that was uh that's kind of a
refreshing trailer to watch that looked
really bad look really fast it looks
like a really good film man like it
doesn't look like most of Lee movies
like yeah doesn't look like every movies
a remake of taking this film looks like
[ __ ] well-made like the drama mystery
looks actually appealing the way it's
shot looks beautiful Liam Neeson is like
doing a great performance apparently he
always does a good job though you know
even in bad movies he does a good job I
want to know about the guy with the
pigeon I don't know why but I think it
was the pigeons he looks cool that's
such an interesting moment because it's
like damn these bad guys must be really
bad if he's just gonna kill himself
right now in a return I get gifts he
must love Christmas he probably kills a
lot of people around Christmas yeah well
thanks for recommending that come
September so I'm birthday is I'm excited
to watch that man if you're new to the
channel subscribe hit the subscribe
button hit the subscribe button yard
you're going to hit that subscribe
button a hey guys I thought it'd be okay
if I give some shoutouts is that Alright
um I know it's like it's kind of weird I
don't usually do this right we thought
it could be like the you know fun thing
the fun thing to try to do every once in
a while we're probably not gonna do it
again maybe if you will respond well to
it yeah téa's ood Mobe I want to shout
out just because now yeah buddy
why would you fit there's a lot of [ __ ]
that's the catch up on here okay well
yeah ha you demand like that you're
gonna have to wait get a ticket wait in
line to say please and thank you
yeah no good arguments he really wants a
shout-out he keeps asking for shoutouts
and so I'm gonna give him a shout-out
because he wants a shout-out no good
arguments no good arguments that's a
horrible thing to name yourself by the
way do you have a good argument for
getting a shout-out
can you give us a good reason to give
you a job and you deserve a shout out
woman see what have you done for us
prove to me that you deserve a shout-out
do you make videos like do you even have
any subscribers are you a new mortgage
shout-out Wow she you went below the
belt there what happens if you ask for
shadow you never know if you're gonna
get a compliment or insulted that's one
of the two Dark Avengers dark Avenger
8:32 he said on the equaliser trailer
video another hilarious video guys can I
possibly have a shout-out there is
someone who's quite yes yes possibly
have a shout-out him
maybe maybe do I really want to give him
a shiny he didn't say please but it's
like you know he's not like saying like
we're he's not commanding us exactly yes
I'm not too much trouble could and I
wasn't too much trouble man so you know
good on you dark Avenger like thinking
about us consider it good guy you're a
good guy you like probably pretty
friendly yeah you know maybe you don't
have any friends but you know people
what matters is one day you might meet
someone you might meet someone one day
yeah who will be your friend maybe
you'll get a girlfriend maybe
yeah oh you know what I think Dark
Avengers gonna be okay gonna be alright
he's gonna be okay he's got like a
minute
yeah he's got spunk you got Moxie kid
you're gonna go far